hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions you may
have seen my video about the average
distance between two points in a unit
square there's an excellent blog post
from Cleve Moler the inventor of MATLAB
that starts as follows
how far apart can you expect two points
chosen at random in the unit square to
be I found this problem on the YouTube
channel maintained by presh tall Walker
mind your decisions he correctly calls
it a very hard puzzle at first I guess
the answer might be one half but the
correct answer is more interesting than
that definitely check out this blog post
and you can also check on my video both
of which are linked in the video
description the problem in this video is
in the spirit of that problem on a
circle with the radius of one pick two
random points on the circumference what
is the average distance between the two
points to be precise imagine a unit
circle centered at 0 0 choose 2 points
with polar coordinates 1 comma theta 1
and 1 comma theta 2 where the angles
theta sub I are distributed uniformly
from 0 to 2 pi find the expected
distance between the points can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem well an
important component is setting it up to
be as simple as possible we'll first put
the circle so its center is at zero zero
next we'll rotate the entire circle and
the points so that p1 is located at 1
comma 0 notice this does not change the
distance between p1 and p2 now what are
the polar coordinates of these points p1
is at 1 comma 0 and p2 is at 1 comma
theta furthermore by symmetry we can
consider just the upper semicircle so we
only consider theta between 0 and pi why
can we do this notice the distance from
P 1 to P 2 in the upper semicircle will
be the same as P 1 2 the symmetric point
P 2 Prime located at 1 comma negative
theta in the lower semicircle hence
removing the lower semicircle will not
affect the average distance because
we're just removing half of the points
which will have the same average as the
upper semicircle so we want to calculate
the distance between P 1 and P 2 how can
we do that
well notice we have the triangle between
P 1 P 2 and 0 0 this side of the
triangle is 1 this side of the triangle
is also 1 and the angle between them is
Theta we can calculate the distance
between P 1 and P 2 using the law of
cosines we get that the distance is
equal to the square root of the
following one squared plus 1 squared
minus 2 times 1 times 1 times the cosine
of theta this simplifies to be the
square root of 2 minus 2 cosine theta
how can we simplify this further I did
not think of this but the technique is
to use the sine half angle formula
the sign of X over two is equal to the
square root of the following one minus
cosine of X all over two therefore we
can write the distance between p1 and p2
as two times a sine of theta over two so
now we have a formula for the distance
between p1 and p2 we now need to
calculate the average value of this
function recall that the average value
of a function from A to B is 1 over B
minus a times the integral from A to B
of the function so we can calculate the
average value of the distance function
as follows our interval will be between
0 and pi so we have 1 over pi minus 0
and then we want the integral from 0 to
PI of 2 times the sine of theta over 2 D
theta it's a straightforward exercise to
calculate this integral we take 1 over
pi times negative 4 cosine of theta over
2 evaluated from 0 to PI and that gets
us to our answer of 4 over pi and that's
approximately one point two seven did
you figure it out thanks for watching
this video these math videos which can
be watched for free on YouTube inspire
and build confidence for people around
the world and they already have over a
hundred million views let's share the
beauty of mathematics with your help we
can math the world a better place please
subscribe for free to get the news
videos watch and share all of mind your
decisions videos and email me a puzzle
or math topic pressure and mind your
decisions calm if you so choose you can
check out my books which are listed in
the video description and you can also
support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support